في بعض الأحيان، كانت هناك لغط حول
تطبيع إسرائيل للعلاقات مع
الدولة العربية الأكثر أهمية،
المملكة العربية السعودية، وسوف تتذكر أن
الإسرائيليين توصلوا إلى صفقات مع العديد من
الدول العربية في اتفاقات إبراهيم التي توسط فيها ترامب
في عام 2020 بشأن صفقة سعودية، والتي
قد تكون لعبة ضخمة.  Changer
وهو أكبر
اتفاق دبلوماسي في المنطقة منذ جيل،
والآن اتفقت الولايات المتحدة والرياض
على الخطوط العريضة لصفقة محتملة
أو على الأقل هذا وفقًا
لتقارير صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال
ردًا على سؤال حول هذا التقرير
لوزارة الخارجية.  وقال متحدث باسم شبكة
CNN، رغم أن المناقشات كانت
مثمرة، إلا أنها لم تصل بعد،
سأقول إننا أجرينا
محادثات مثمرة، وهناك عدد من القضايا
التي ناقشناها مع كل من
الحكومة الإسرائيلية ومع
الحكومة السعودية، وتستمر تلك المحادثات
وأتوقع أن تستمر هناك  سيحدث المزيد في
الأسابيع المقبلة، لقد أحرزنا تقدمًا في
عدد من القضايا، لن أتطرق
إلى ماهية التقدم ولكن لا يزال هناك
طريق طويل لنقطعه مع
مستقبل غير مؤكد ولكنها
مبادرة مهمة  نعتقد أننا
يجب أن نستمر في متابعة
مشاعر مماثلة "صدى الحروب" من قبل
مستشار الأمن القومي الإسرائيلي، الذي أخبرت شبكة CNN أن الولايات المتحدة
تبقي إسرائيل على اطلاع وثيق للغاية
بالمناقشات مع الرياض، لكن
لم يحدث الكثير ومن المحتمل
ألا يتم التوصل إلى اتفاق، كما يقول.  قبل نهاية
العام، لا يوجد شخص أفضل
لتحليل كل هذا من
محررنا الدبلوماسي الدولي
نيك روبرتسون الذي ينضم إلي الآن في
الاستوديو حتى نعرف في هذا النوع من
التثليث الذي يحدث أن كل
جانب في الواقع في منطقتنا  تخبرنا المصادر
بالتأكيد أن الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل
حريصتان جدًا على التطبيع، ونحن نعلم ذلك
وبالتأكيد نسمع خلف الكواليس أن هناك
بالتأكيد نداءً
للسعوديين ولكن هناك خطوطًا حمراء وهي
مسألة كيفية التفاوض حول
هذا الأمر، لذا أعتقد أن  السؤال الأول هو
ما مدى قربهم من التطبيع في
هذه المرحلة من وجهة نظر سعودية أه من
وجهة نظر سعودية أمريكية هناك بعض الأشياء
التي يبدو أن لها تلك الخطوط العريضة التي
يتحركون بها وهي
أن الولايات المتحدة يمكن أن تساعد
المملكة العربية السعودية  تطوير
نظام طاقة نووية محلي للطاقة للبلد الذي يبدو أنه مما
نسمعه يحدث
أن السعوديين يريدون طائرات مقاتلة من طراز F-35
من الولايات المتحدة جيدًا، وكذلك الحال بالنسبة
لكل دولة أخرى تقريبًا كحليف
في العالم، ولكن هذا أيضًا  شيء
يبدو أنه يتمتع بمستوى من
الجاذبية، وبالتأكيد جلب السعوديون
كمية هائلة من الأسلحة من
الولايات المتحدة في الماضي، ومن
المثير للاهتمام أن أحد الأجزاء الأخرى
التي يتم
تداولها نوعًا ما والتي نسمع عنها
هو  السعودية تريد نوعًا ما من
النموذج القديم، نموذج الأمن القديم
لنموذج الطاقة ولكن أعتقد أن هناك
نموذجًا قد تغير أيضًا، لذلك هذا هو
السياق،
هناك جزء يريدونه
من الإسرائيليين وذلك من
مصادري السعودية  ويقولون إنهم غير
متأكدين من قدرة الإسرائيليين على تقديم
ضمانات معينة للفلسطينيين